on gagne combien par mois quand on
s'appelle Benjamin Castaldi surtout
quand est-ce qu'on ferme sa bouche merci
Jordan Jordan qui vont trouver tous les
jours sur C8 oui oui tous les jours
il arrive à faire sortir des choses
j'ai fait votre femme il y a pas
longtemps
c'est pas une piste de ski hein
[Applaudissements]
encore que
alors oui non
parce que quand on fait votre émission
c'était le meilleur score cette semaine
ma femme euh oui bah en fait ça a monté
quand elle a parlé de vous parce que dès
que vous en fait donc il faut pas parler
les infidélités
[Rires]
de d'oseille aussi oui je sais aller
50000 euros bah oui elle m'a appelé ça
allait pas du tout
dans l'idéal ce qu'elle aimerait avoir
voilà je sais bien j'ai eu au téléphone
elle était pas contente du tout bah oui
mais vous vous m'avez appelé aussi
sur le l'argent et il lui a demandé dans
l'idéal combien est-ce que il vous
faudrait par mois pour bien vivre alors
elle a dit bah dans l'idéal si je devais
donner à tout le monde et cetera pour
donner à droite à gauche et être très à
l'aise ce serait 50 milles alors et du
coup après pour faire du clic forcément
ça fait de la claque très loin
je vous dirai plus tard